one of the most important questions in
the robert muller investigation into
trump russia is are they going to talk
to Donald Trump right we know that
Robert Mulder's team wants to speak to
Trump we saw a list of nearly 50
questions that would be possible
questions for that meeting or that
exchange and at this point the major
question that I have is is there going
to be an in-person sit-down between
Robert Moeller or his investigators and
the President of the United States are
they going to agrees to a sort of
interview in writing where Trump's
lawyers will get to write down Donald
Trump's answers to questions and if the
desire is for an in-person meeting is
Trump going to agree to that meeting or
is robert muller going to have to
subpoena donald trump and if so is he
willing to issue that subpoena if there
is a subpoena will there be a debate as
to the strength and power of a subpoena
of the sitting president of the United
States we don't have answers to a lot of
these questions yet but what we did
learn in the last twelve hours is that
when robert muller met with donald
trump's lawyers in march just weeks ago
the meeting was very tense because there
were actually disagreements about robert
muller subpoena power and robert muller
did threaten a subpoena and this is very
very quickly escalating we know based on
a very good Washington Post report by
Carol lone aghh and Robert Kosta and
Kosta has been doing really good
reporting for the last year on this
first of all during this meeting in
March 2017 Trump's lawyers insisted
Trump has no obligation to speak to
Moeller period basically saying listen
if we do anything it's because we're
gonna choose to do it not because we
have to do it and Muller during the same
meeting made it clear actually that's
not true
I could subpoena the President of the
United States and force him to testify
before a grand jury for people familiar
with the situation spoke to the
Washington Post about this and this is
major for a number of different reasons
number one is that up until now we know
that the opinion of trumps lawyers has
been that they don't want Trump to talk
to Muller but now we know that they also
think Trump doesn't have to talk to
Muller which is a very very different
set of beliefs if you are Donald Trump's
legal
this report from the Washington Post is
also huge because even though we all
knew that subpoenas are possible from
Robert Moeller right in a sort of
general sense we didn't know whether or
not Muller had actually mentioned that
possibility of a subpoena to Donald
Trump's team and indeed according to
this report he did trumps now resigned
lawyer from back in March of 2017 John
Dowd reportedly was not at all happy
with Muller when Muller mentioned this
saying this isn't some kind of game you
were screwing with the work of the
President of the United States we now
know that this meeting not going well
was the catalyst for molars team sending
over information to the Trump legal team
that became the list of nearly 50
questions that we talked about yesterday
and Trump's seemingly not reacting well
at all to this tweeting again about a
witch hunt
weird capitalization throughout this
entire thing this morning saying there
was no collusion it is a hoax hoax
capitalized of course and there is no
obstruction of justice that is a setup
and trap what there is is negotiations
going on with North Korea over nuclear
war negotiations going on with China
over trade deficits negotiations on
NAFTA and much more witch-hunt
and because the subpoena news is so big
it's actually gotten lost in all of this
that this Washington Post piece also
confirms that the leaked Trump was mad
about yesterday Trump said that
yesterday was disgraceful that these
questions leaked the leak is from it's
coming from inside the house quite
literally the White House either Trump
or his team leaked the questions because
we now know that list of 49 questions
was not a list provided by robert muller
that was a list of questions compiled or
created by trump's lawyer jay sekulow as
possible questions meaning that since
it's Trump's lawyers list someone in
Trump's staff leaked the list and I
think that that's actually part of the
plan right the idea here of leaking
these questions is to make it appear as
though Robert Muller is getting a little
too broad in his reach that molars going
too far and that it all just lacks
legitimate
see because once the questions are
public you can say look at all the stuff
molars going into and also the fact that
the questions themselves are public D
legitimizes the sort of privacy of the
entire organization this was no doubt a
calculated leak from the Trump White
House and if it wasn't Trump's got a
major problem if someone within his team
is choosing to leak these questions so I
believe that there is no question that
to have a truly full and fair hearing of
what Donald Trump knew or is willing to
admit knowing molars going to need a
subpoena I don't know if we will get
that subpoena but this written set of
questions that Muller could send over to
Trump to then have his lawyers answer
that's not going to clear anything up
okay and hopefully we will get that
subpoena soon and there are people who
will say David isn't it disruptive to
government to the office of the
presidency to subpoena the President of
the United States shouldn't we consider
that this is too important to accept
anything but the fullest possible
answers to what it is that Trump did and
what it is that Trump knew and the way
to get that at this point is gonna
happen one of one ways which is skilled
investigators talking to Donald Trump in
a live setting if you don't believe that
the subpoena is necessary to get to the
truth let me know I'm on twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show today's episode of the
program is made possible in part by
Coins schedule a listing site for
initial coin offerings that's been
around since 2016 was actually one of
the first websites to show listing
information about icos you can look them
up by name type of Industry the icos
end date the start date and it also
gives each IC o---- a score using an
algorithm based on dozens of parameters
to help you determine how trustworthy
and ico is very important to be able to
filter out scams so for example whether
or not the identities of the ico team
are verified is listed by coin schedule
whether the IC o---- has a white paper
these types of parameters and coin
schedule also doesn't try to make
predictions about the long-term success
or failure of any IC o---- projects
since this is
often impossible what they do instead is
provide users with a combined score of
how much operational risk coins schedule
sees for each different ICO so that you
can know when you've got to be careful
with I cos that have a low rating if
you're watching this on YouTube I've put
a link to the coin schedule website at
the top of the video description and of
course nothing in coin schedule should
be considered personalized investment
advice icos are risky people should do
their own research and make their own
decisions